okay so question why back in the day was
Steve always like Brad Martin sold me
drugs how the [__] did that start it was
a joke uh tell the real story oh okay
that's thick boy exclusive this is a
real this is I've actually I don't think
I've ever oh damn I don't know if I
could really admit this basically at one
point in my life I needed money and I
and I did things that I shouldn't have
done for money
at one point and he knew that so Steve
is Steve's the kind of person like he'll
make jokes that like kind of like dance
that line yeah so because he knew that
one piece of information he like ran
with it and it just stuck it was funny
so now like even saying your comments
people like yo you sell drugs
still it's been years since that joke
yeah that's hilarious I imagine I
imagine why don't you make merch well
they did they made millions and millions
of dollars from merge I made none of it
oh well that's not cool I think I don't
know
Steve made millions of dollars hey Steve
yeah bro